[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance Donald Trump's propagandists
and apologists have chosen to defend
Trump on Russia by attacking a murdered
27 year old man and torturing his
parents in public and may they burn in
hell for doing so if you do not know
this story you are lucky but you should
hear it because it underscores yet again
the lengths to which those who enabled
Trump to seize power in our country will
defend that power and him there are no
standards there are no morals there are
no ethics there are only Kellyanne
Conway's alternative facts and there are
vermin like Newt Gingrich and Sean
Hannity and people who put them into
American homes without filter or
fact-check like Roger Ailes who died
last week and about whom if he had been
a liberal Newt Gingrich and Sean Hannity
would probably right now be pushing a
conspiracy theory proving that he hails
and not the Russians nor anybody working
for Trump hacked the DNC computers a
year ago last July the 27 year old man
Seth rich was found murdered on a
Washington Street it would insult his
memory and his loved ones to
characterize what happened to him as
commonplace but the evidence is all too
familiar it was a botched robbery it
remains an unsolved murder and an open
case and Seth rich happened to work for
the Democratic National Committee last
year flailing about for somebody on whom
to pin the DNC computer hacking the
alt-right media seized on Seth rich who
had just been murdered they said he had
hacked the Democrats on behalf of
WikiLeaks and had then been assassinated
even though the consumer of alt-right
media is the easiest audience in the
world they bought Donald Trump didn't
they the Seth rich hacked the DNC story
went nowhere because there wasn't even
enough in it to make a good conspiracy
theory for people who will believe
anything that was before the Russia
hacking dragnet reportedly detected at
least one person of interest inside
Trump's White House and that was before
a Fox News legal commentator named rod
wheeler gave an interview to a news
reporter at the Fox station in
Washington named marina marraco you have
information that could link Seth rich to
wiki
Leakes asked Marco absolutely replied
wheeler yeah that's confirmed it wasn't
none of it was confirmed there was no
information in the Fox report wheeler
was shown quoting a police source saying
they were told to stand down on the
investigation he spoke of a correlation
between the Washington mayor's office
and the DNC without even hinting at what
the hell he meant by his misuse of the
word correlation wheeler said the police
had Rich's laptop or maybe it was the
FBI that had it Marco's Fox report
identified wheeler as the rich family
investigator something he was not he was
hired by a third party a man named edy
Bukowski at Bukowski's expense and
Buttowski just happens to be another Fox
News contributor within a day of the
Mehra Court on Fox's Washington Station
the only source for it the Fox News
contributor wheeler who was referred by
the Fox News contributor butowski had
not only recanted and said he had no
evidence that there was a laptop or a
stand-down order or a correlation but he
also told CNN quote I only got that from
the reporter at Fox News the story
promptly collapsed again it was a murder
it was the tragedy of a life census Lee
cut short but it was not even enough to
make it to a conspiracy theory that
these right-wing idiots would believe
and then came Sean Hannity I have
mentioned before that I used to know him
I used to work in a radio studio
adjoining his in New York City and that
he marveled to me and how seriously
people took what he said and how anybody
thought it was anything more than a job
to him and how they expected that he
hated me when I would slam him when in
fact the publicity he said increased his
ratings and he said with a laugh all he
cared about were his ratings last
Thursday afternoon on that same radio
show it was just a job to him Hannity
said this to those who would criticize
him apparently I care more about why
this kid was murdered than you do you
know why isn't a member of you know why
didn't they offer a reward did Seth rich
have a computer and if he did where is
it I hope and pray I pray for this kid
this family but I don't believe this
story about robbery for one second and I
don't like being lied to and the family
shouldn't like being lied to that's
their
business I pray for them as I pray for
you Hannity if many of the world's
religions are correct you're going to be
in hell a long time that was Thursday
afternoon Friday morning our time this
was tweeted WikiLeaks informer Seth rich
murdered in US but British MSM was so
busy accusing Russian hackers to take
notice that was from the ever reliable
objective and totally disinterested
Twitter account of the Russian embassy
in London the Russian embassy and on
Sunday Newt Gingrich who has often on
been a Fox News employee ever since he
lost his job as Speaker of the House
while he unsuccessfully was trying to
get Bill Clinton to lose his job as
president went back on Fox News talking
about the new Justice Department Trump
Russia Special Counsel Robert Miller and
he invoked Seth rich quote who
apparently was assassinated at 4:00 in
the morning having given WikiLeaks
something like 53,000 emails and 17,000
attachments where did Gingrich get those
numbers from a Fox News report quoting
an anonymous federal investigator
nobodies investigating that and what
does that tell you about what's going on
because it turns out it wasn't the
Russians of course it wasn't the
Russians Newt they sent out a tweet
saying it wasn't them it was Seth rich
what possible motive would they have to
lie to you Newt it was this young guy
who I suspect was disgusted by the
corruption of the Democratic National
Committee that part Gingrich himself
made up he's been killed and apparently
nothing serious has been done to
investigate his murder so I'd like to
see how Muller is going to define what
his assignment is so that is Fox News
analyst Newt Gingrich lying about a lie
spread by Fox News host Sean Hannity
picked up from Oh Fox Washington news
reporter quoting as her only named
source a Fox News contributor who was
referred by another Fox News contributor
Hannity smells ratings or whatever it is
one smells standing that close to Donald
Trump Sunday night Congress investigates
Seth rich murder Julian Assange made
comments you need to listen to if Seth
was wiki source
no Trump Russia collusion he then quotes
a German than Kim Schmidt's who
self-identifies as kim.com who claims he
has relevant evidence but conveniently
will not produce it these pigs Hannity
Schmidt's comm Buttowski wheeler
Gingrich Gingrich the pig who was so
eager to marry his mistress that he
pestered his first wife over their
divorce while that first wife was in the
hospital who then cheated on his second
wife with the woman who would become his
third wife who inexplicably just became
Trump's pick for ambassador to the
Vatican Gingrich and these other pigs
ran this same heartless fiendish scheme
two decades ago on the family of a
Clinton lawyer named Vince Foster and
this time may have the help of the
internet and the Russians to run it
again
and the lack of humanity and complete
inability to prioritize what they want
versus how they should let a family
grieve knows no bounds
Seth Rich's family first pleaded then
begged and then demanded that the memory
of their son not for political gain be
urinated upon that's my word urinated
upon the response they got Hannity and
Gingrich and another scum called huffed
who runs a propaganda site called
gateway pundits to whom Donald Trump's
minions have given White House press
credentials on Sunday HOF to tweeted
this link to a video breaking video Seth
Rich's parents grateful for assistance
finding son's killers no indication they
want it stopped the video is a month old
it is
Seth Rich's parents on a video in which
they thanked those who had contributed
to a GoFundMe campaign to help them with
their considerable expenses after their
son's murder their video has nothing to
do with thanking the Trump crowds
soulless exploitation of their son's
murder
these subhuman creatures these Trump
apologists these Gingrich's these
Schmidt sees these Hannity's these
Hoth's these wheelers they could not
even leave the parents that the video Oh
in the origin point here that Fox
Washington report from this dolt
local reporter named Merrick oh that got
this indefensible entire distraction
from Trump's Russia scandal rolling
again permitting Fox News to quote Fox
News to be quoted by Fox News on Fox
News as of Monday afternoon americo's
tweet promoting her thoroughly
discredited reporting on a Fox station
licensed by the FCC was still live quote
new Seth Richardson apartment detective
and tells Fox 5 DC tonight
there is evidence rich was emailing with
WikiLeaks that is the case for the
defense of Donald Trump and the Trump
campaign and the Trump White House and
the Russians and they can all burn in
hell resist peace